hello I'm Katie Nolan and today we're
gonna talk about Gloria Steinem our
story begins in the year 1963 Gloria
Steinem was a graduate of Smith College
very smart she's 28 years old and she's
a journalist and show Magazine was like
hey Gloria we have a story for you we
want you to go undercover at one of Hugh
Hefner's Playboy Clubs and Playboy Clubs
were advertising themselves at the time
as like being in a real live version of
Playboy she would have like beautiful
women everywhere and drinks and food and
dude stuff yeah boobies and vaginas and
Gloria was like I don't think this is
what I want I want people to take me
seriously
and her editor was like I think this
could be your chance to call Hugh Hefner
out on his goddamn and she was
like you're right I'm in let's do it
what was I talking about
so she says yes to the thing to the
assignment and so she goes to the
audition which is at a Playboy Club so
she's this alias she's created for
herself which is Murray Katheryn Oates
and the woman that she goes up to Fez
take off your coat let me see your body
Gloria was like okay and like took her
coat off the woman was like you look a
little old for 24 but your body's great
come back on Saturday for a fitting and
so Gloria comes back a couple days later
and sherilee just like i'm the bunny
mother so she goes and she gets sighs
she puts on this leotard and she's like
this fits no I know it doesn't and they
keep going in and in and Gloria is like
I said risk an IceCube just assaulted
you got Isis so the bunny mother Cheryl
E is explaining to the bunnies there's
all these things that they can take your
money away for like if your ears are on
crooked that's a demerit your bunny tail
is dirty
that's demerits if you're not smiling
enough that's a bunch of demerits they
also give her this bunny manual which is
a list of all the rules that you have to
follow in the bunny manual it says
you're not allowed to date any customers
but then they were told unless they hold
the special key these special key
members were allowed to do whatever they
want you know uh duh anyway so they're
like great you're all set you're gonna
start work soon we just need you to
complete your physical and Gloria is
like what do you mean I'm gonna be a
waitress
oh we just need you to complete a
physical with this doctor and then
you'll be fine to start despero's yeah
that's just gross
so just cuz the doctor she sits on the
table
and she sees their stirrups and the
doctor walks in and the first thing he
says tourists so you want to be a bunny
which is alarming as a doctor he exams
her which to a woman means you know you
say it's not a bagel Derek it's a so she
finishes the exam and she goes the next
day to train for this job that's a fancy
word for you're gonna work and not get
paid any money she's training as a table
bunny and they teach her that she just
has to follow the other bunny servers
around and so she's going around asking
people like hello I'm bunny Murray
what can I get for you and they would
say things like yeah girl let me see
your titties open it up which is
how many times you're allowed to say
on Comedy Central's set it a
whole bunch whatever you want okay it's
emotion I may teach out of bunny yes all
right so when I walk how do I walk well
so it'll be on a tray and then I need
you to be on your tippy toes all the way
up higher than this is all you go and
then cross your legs when you walk and
over the table to serve the drink but
out mm-hmm titties out
go away anyway she's working all
these shifts and she's like in her
journal she's writing all these in
Justices they're like working these long
hours there
making any money on top of that it's
basically a prostitution ring and after
working in the playboy clubs for four
weeks Gloria it was like this I
have enough in my journal I'm gonna
publish this I'm out it's just all
the stupid sexist dumbass she
just wanted to get the book and so she
quit and so Gloria write to expose on
these Playboy Clubs
she's like these women were like not
making as much money as they were told
they were gonna make
it's insane hours they're being grabbed
all the time they're treated like
prostitutes they're basically being used
as a tool for the male sexual revolution
but the women themselves don't get to
own their sexuality and that's shitty so
they publicist just they publishes they
bubble they publish they publish the
story in the magazine so the world reads
this article and to is very tiny credit
Hugh Hefner says wow yeah maybe they
won't have to go to these physical exams
anymore and you know what I'm gonna stop
making them have to give so much of
their money to us if they make a mistake
which is like a really cool thing that
Hugh Hefner did but also not as cool as
just like always treating them that way
this article made Gloria Steinem a
household name and she went on to be
this huge feminist icon it's tough but I
swear to God if it weren't for Gloria
Steinem I wouldn't be able to be on TV
it's very hard to be a woman that's like
I love sports you have stuck to your
guns ever since you started and that is
what you cried I'm sorry can I get
somebody else to do do this
[Laughter]
[Music]